heads up guys my name is eterno welcome
back to my code review Series where you
guys send me your beautiful code and I
take a look at it so
it's the end of the trilogy over the
last couple of videos we've been looking
at the same project a 2d physics engine
but we've been looking at very different
parts of it in the first video we talked
about memory in the second video we
talked about how to read code that
you've never read before we focused on
pretty much everything there is in this
project except for the actual physics
engine and considering this project is a
physics engine I think it's about time
for the finale So today we're going to
jump in and take a look at the physics
part of this project and I highly
recommend you take a look at those first
two videos also as always the link to
this code will be in the description
below so you guys can take a look at it
for yourselves unless the author decides
to like delete it or something okay so
looking at the project obviously in this
actual physics engine kind of module
this is where everything exists so let's
kind of go through this I know this is
inspired by that like designing a
physics engine in five minutes video all
the way back in the first episode when
we read Stowe's like original email to
us he did mention that so I'm expecting
the design is going to be a little a bit
similar to that but basically if we take
a look at this API it can be a little
bit difficult to just see exactly where
everything is done so whenever you look
at any API in fact when you're designing
an API as well I always say this start
with the actual usage of it so in other
words how are you going to use this API
it's really difficult to just make an
API by just starting to write one of
these files right what you should do is
go to a place where you're actually
going to use it so for example inside
this demo balls and Cube we see like
these like solvers being created we see
the world actually being kind of set up
over here and then we call world.step
that shows me what I actually need to
create in my API so for example I need a
step function that takes this in I need
to have a way to like update the
entities etc etc so from looking at this
what I can kind of see is that inside
this run function which is very
important because this is what happens
every frame by the way I should probably
show this to you guys if you haven't
seen it from the previous episodes why
did that open twice what's this extra
window it's a bit weird does that always
happen it does why are you opening up an
extra window I didn't notice this last
time the heck's going on all right let's
just ignore that so basically we can
click to kind of spawn in these um
spheres I was going to say with their
circles and then also we have uh these
guys which don't
I can't tell if they're colliding I
guess they are colliding with each other
I guess if they're already inside each
other they don't like pop out or
something but
um we have these kind of squares and
yeah these guys actually do pop out if
they're inside each other so I'm not
sure maybe like it's weird because if I
drop these two
yeah they Collide properly so it's a
little weird but anyway this is the
result basically I don't know what this
additional window is we could take a
look at fixing that later but I promised
we would focus on the physics so let's
get back into it if we click the mouse
buttons it's also important to see what
actually happens you can see all really
all we really do is push back entities
so we make a new Circle and push it back
into this entities list and then we go
through all of them and we update them
and we step the world so the thing is
it's obviously important like Circle
when we create a new Circle we also pass
in World which is a little bit of an
interesting design like why you why does
a circle need to know about the world
theoretically this isn't like a bad
design per se but it's just it's just
implemented a little in a little bit of
a weird way but anyway so we call entity
entity has a Dynamics world and then we
just set that okay over here I was
expecting that it would add it into this
world because obviously this world
itself should probably okay so this
doesn't actually contain any okay
Collision and wild and then that's yeah
okay that contains the actual Collision
Bodies Okay so with this is kind of the
meat of it this kind of kind of
collision world that we have have over
here and specifically this header file
did I
did I not tell you guys about brilliant
the sponsor of this video ah time flies
when you're code reviewing if you guys
haven't heard of brilliant brilliant is
an amazing website filled with so many
different courses on various stem topics
and they have one of the best
collections of math courses on the
entire internet in my honest opinion
whether you're just starting your math
journey or you're trying to learn the
math that you need for 3D rendering such
as vectors and calculus brilliant have a
huge collection of really engaging and
visual courses on all of these topics
they have these great interactive
widgets you can play with to actually
understand the math on a deeper level
and they'll quiz you asking you
questions every step of the way so that
you actually learn and retain this
information the best thing about
brilliant is you can get started
completely for free just go to
brilliant.org the channel link will be
in the description below check it out
for yourselves just go through their
courses and see if you like them and if
you do brilliant have been nice enough
to offer the first 200 of my subscribers
20 off an annual membership huge thank
you to brilliant as always for
sponsoring this video we have an
unordered map of bodies and we have a
vector of solvers so I'm wondering why
so this is an unordered map and it's
probably mapping from some kind of ID if
I had to guess to a uh to a pointer of
collision bodies and these are just all
of the bodies that exist within our
Collision world and then I'm guessing
that basically by where are we over here
by actually clicking like our Mouse
button we
will be adding
them into it but where does it actually
get added into the world because it
doesn't look like it has to though
because you can see here that the
destructor of entity actually removes it
from the world
but what adds it to the world okay so
it's each individual entity itself I
wonder why it's set up that way
I guess because maybe the actual type
that it adds is different so you can see
that for example Circle in case you're
lost because this is getting a little
bit confusing potentially so we push
back an entity over here it's a circle
circle is an entity right but Circle
also has a Constructor and even though
that does call the base Constructor over
here and it does do some things to set
it up such as like set the transform for
the rigid body do all of this stuff
right the actual Circle Constructor
itself also will add itself kind of to
the Dynamics well now it's not really
adding itself it's actually creating a
brand new Rigid body I guess which
represents this and add and adds it into
the Dynamics world and then technically
speaking the circle itself is not really
part of the Dynamics world it's actually
stored inside this like entities Vector
which is a vector of unique pointers a
vector of entities so that's kind of
interesting so add rigid body
we'll add so here we are creating some
kind of new Rigid body
oh we're not creating a new Rigid body
man that is so annoying
okay
this is the worst I did not know this
was a function I thought this was
like the Constructor of an object I
thought you were making a new object
here because I thought that rigid body
so rigid body is actually a function
yeah this makes more sense now which
Returns the rigid body of I guess the
entity
so this is kind of interesting so what
happens then is we construct a new
Circle the first thing that happens is
we call the entity Constructor so the
base Constructor the base Constructor
will go ahead and create a new Rigid
body like this and then we go ahead and
actually add the rigid body back in the
circle Constructor into the Dynamics
world so the existing rigid body we're
not creating a new Rigid body here where
just returning the one that exists in
the actual entity so I'm not sure why
this line of code is here like you could
have just put this in
um the base
Constructor like that right so it's
because obviously Dynamics world is
owned by The Entity and so is this you
know rigid body which is effectively
what's going on here I guess the only
reason why you probably didn't do that
well the only valid reason anyway is
probably because maybe some maybe like
some other objects so like a box for
example they don't they they do
something a little bit different so this
no I mean this also does the exact same
line of code and so does this okay and I
think that's all of your shapes so
basically this should be in the base is
the way I see it um but yeah I totally
thought you were just making a new one
because obviously like a rigid body
itself here I mean you're using pointers
for everything but this is obviously
just an object over here and you could
have just you know kind of constructed
it like this that's what I thought was
going on but obviously this actually
requires a pointer and then this itself
will return that raw pointer from that
unique pointer so
um it's a little bit messy see to be
honest I think what's going on here is
you're taking in a raw pointer here and
you're adding it you're calling out a
collision body There Goes My syntax
highlighting thank you
um you're adding your Collision body and
you're doing bodies insert body ID body
and then that I'm sure stores Collision
body so I'm not so this is interesting
because we can kind of talk a little bit
about ownership semantics here
um which is clearly my favorite thing to
to talk about uh even though I said I'd
focus on the physics this is physics
related guys this is physics related the
thing that's interesting about this is
that we're falling back to using raw
pointers because what we kind of want is
kind of like a weak ref right we like I
mean that's what I assume is going on
right you kind of want to add a rigid
body but you don't want it to be owning
exactly which is is already weird I
think because like when you add a rigid
body and it adds in and all this stuff
the rigid body itself we know we're
actually adding to the Dynamics world
and then is getting inserted into this
along with its ID right into this map
but the question is does this own the
body
or does it not meaning like should this
keep the object alive or should it not
because obviously the way you've got it
set up is that this is kind of like a
weak pointer right meaning that like
it's not going to keep the object alive
I mean obviously we're talking about
unique pointers not shared pointers it's
not reference counted it can't keep it
alive even if it was storing like unique
pointers and that maybe wouldn't even
make sense but my point is like I guess
what I'm trying to say is that whenever
you find yourself dealing with pointers
like raw pointers like this
uh which is usually quite common it
depends what kind of stuff you're
working on but pointers obviously are
very very common and even though you
could theoretically probably like avoid
using pointers altogether if you just
use like shared pointers for everything
and you just never even touch draw
pointers raw pointers are probably going
to keep coming up so whenever you see a
raw pointer here and this is why
everyone is so afraid of them I
personally think that's a bit dramatic
but whatever is because when you see
something like this the kind of
intentions or the semantics of this
specific I guess at the end of the day
is just a block of memory that this is
pointing to are very unclear like for
example we don't know whether or not
this bodies is supposed to be the
authority that actually frees the memory
if it's removed for example from this
map or maybe it's supposed to kind of
read only in the sense that like if the
object's available access me if it's not
then don't and that's why it's kind of
scary because but just by looking at
this and just by having all of these
kind of raw pointers floating around
everywhere it's very unclear whether or
not this kind of collision body object
inside my body's map is even going to
exist in in the first place right so
here's the thing like even though you're
using smart pointers this kind of ties
into new and delete it's basically the
same thing because inside the entity
Constructor what are you doing you're
creating the object but then the circle
Constructor actually adds it to the map
by calling add rigid body and then the
entity Destructor what does it do it
removes it from the map so you've kind
of got a new in the Constructor and a
delete in the destructor it's the same
thing why because this rigid body is a
unique pointer which means that
obviously if we're in the destructor of
entity entity is about to die and entity
is the thing that is actually holding
this rigid body which is a unique point
of meaning it's going to die as well so
therefore we have to remove it from this
map which again I think is kind of
hilarious in a way because all of the C
plus plus people are all about like oh
yeah you should never you know create a
new entity on the the Heap by calling
new that's banned or why because you
have to call delete and that you might
miss that and that's like a memory leak
well the same thing is happening here
we're adding a collision body here and
we're removing a collision body here and
if we forget to remove it we're not
technically leaking memory but what are
we doing we're storing a pointer to
memory that has already been freed and
if we try and access that we'll crash so
arguably it's actually even worse than a
memory leak having an invalid pointer is
probably more dangerous than simply
leaking memory so yeah just something to
think about now if you want a solution
to this like to be honest I can't say
that there's a straightforward solution
to this that doesn't actually affect the
way your code works but but it is
possible technically and this would
introduce a little bit of overhead and
probably isn't what you want but just as
an example what you could do is you
could kind of promote this to be a
shared pointer and the advantage of that
is that because shared pointers are a
little bit more complicated in their
implementation it means that you can do
some extra things with them such as
storing a weak pointer and theirs is a
completely different story the only real
disadvantage of this apart from again
the fact that it's obviously a reference
counted system it's going to atomically
increment a decrement there's going to
be a little bit of performance overhead
to that semantically the difference is
that now this is not the be-all end-all
owning object of this specific rigid
body it can technically be shared
however if you don't share it what this
does enable you to do is have a weak
pointer here which is a non-owning
reference meaning that whilst this map
does actually contain a body what you
can do is every time you're about to use
it and potentially dereference memory
that may have been freed you can ask the
weak pointer hey are you a valid object
if not remove it from the body's map if
yes then proceed now is this something I
would do for this system
probably not even though it might seem
like I'm critical of just using a raw
pointer here I'm not I'm not exactly I
just kind of wanted to discuss like what
you need to be aware of when you do
write code like this because it might
not be even something you think about if
you don't have much experience but it
should be something you think about like
memory and ownership semantics
fortunately unfortunately depending on
if you enjoy it or not are just a
fundamental part of programming in c
plus plus I'm Banning myself from
talking about anything else other than
the physics let's actually take a look
at how you resolve collisions and all of
that so if we go back into uh so we're
in Collision world I mean solve
collisions right I know from looking at
Collision wild that you actually have it
looks like you've separated your bodies
and your solvers that's good
um it's always good to just to kind of
separate these things because at the end
of the day what are Collision bodies
they're just like they store our data
they're just basically buffers a memory
that tell us like okay where is the body
what is its size what is its shape like
what are the other physics parameters of
it such as like the restitution The
Bouncing as you know friction whatever
all of those kind of parameters is
basically just data only and then what a
solvers they're kind of our actual
systems so if you look at this from like
an entity component System point of view
right this is kind of like the component
and this is the system and then of
course the entity is like what holds
them together I guess so this kind of
separation is always good so if we go
back into Collision World solve
collisions what happens so this actually
iterates over all of the solvers and it
solves all of the collisions that are
given to it so let's kind of see where
solve collisions is actually called from
so resolve collisions calls it uh and
then when where's that coming from
Dynamics World step okay so we're kind
of back to uh our main kind of file
which is our our application Loop so
that calls World step World step applies
gravity resolves collisions and move
body so let's kind of go through this
and see what's up so apply gravity first
of all we'll iterate through all of the
bodies that we have in our world and it
will simply apply a gravity force to it
very simple we have gravity force we
multiply that with the mass we create a
force and then we apply Force which I'm
guessing is as simple as just doing
Force plus equals added force all very
simple and then next step is to resolve
collisions we have a vector of
collisions that have been detected
Vector for collisions have been caused
by trigger colliders okay cool we
support triggers as well that's nice
update the grid and find the object that
can collide together so what is update
the grid okay broad face grid right so
we're even we even have some kind of
like partitioning system here to make
sure that we're not just trying to
collide every single object with every
single object in our scene so what I
mean by that is for example if we take a
look at this if we're trying to figure
out the Collision for this circle why
would we test it against this like could
you imagine focusing on this circle
because that's the guy I'm currently
like resolving right and then iterating
through every single object in this
entire world trying to see if they
Collide like isn't that just a complete
waste of time instead what we can do is
create like a partitioning system where
we basically can like okay there's many
ways to do this but let me just quickly
explain one way so what we could do is
basically create something like a grid
right it doesn't even have to be a quad
tree it doesn't have to be anything like
fancy we can just create a grid so
here's our little grid what does this do
it literally just divides the world into
cells and what's the advantage of this
you say well if where specifically
focusing on this particular object here
what do we know we know that it can
really only collide with objects inside
its own cell there's no way you can
collide with something over here but
what if it's this object you say isn't
this object in between like both of
these cells yes so what you can do is
you can actually expand it and again
just like for a naive kind of
implementation you could say that okay
all of the adjacent cells are included
as well right because if you think about
it there's no way you can pick an object
here like even if it's this guy or here
that's affecting all of these there's no
way that you can pick this where the
center point obviously is uh technically
I guess in this cell there's no way you
could pick this and then not include all
the adjacent cells and somehow end up
with it colliding with something that
isn't in this kind of group of cells
like that's impossible right it will
always be just these so you can see how
much this narrows it down like it's
important to partition your world and
have some kind of spatial partitioning
system would be like the correct term
for that this is used a lot everywhere
it's used a lot in 3D games it's used a
lot in 2D games and obviously not just
games I'm using games as an example but
just in like rendering in general or
like physics simulations there's so many
uses for this even just dealing with
large data sets because the more you
narrow the code down the more you can
avoid doing kind of expensive math to
check like the way that all this
Collision is actually happening now of
course special partitioning systems
could be a little bit more if asking
this like we could go into something
called a quad tree which is where what
we have is kind of narrowing down of
cells so in other words you kind of
have this situation where where instead
of just being a flat grid of cells like
this you start off I'm going to draw
this in blue you start off by just
having this kind of quad tree where you
just have one of four kind of cells here
instead of just having like a you know a
kind of even uniform distribution of of
cells across the whole world and then
you just ask yourself okay well which
cell is this guy in oh it's in this top
left one cool so what I'm going to do is
now divide this into like four cells and
then again I'll ask myself where where
are you oh you're in this one here cool
let me divide this into four and so on
and so forth and see clearly you're kind
of narrowing down exactly where in the
world this guy is and what other
entities are also in that kind of space
but anyway my point through all of this
is just to mention that when we do have
a setup like this and you are dealing
with a lot of objects it's really
important to be able to kind of minimize
the amount of math that you're doing
between them because that's going to be
a major bottleneck and that's what this
face grid is probably doing there's
actually a lot of comments here which I
really like so a grid in which the
physical objects are placed in this used
to optimize performance by the chain
conclusion colliders that are in the
same cell okay yeah I mean pretty pretty
basic I'm not a genius or anything it's
just that this is a very common concept
of course it also looks like this class
is pretty generic in the sense that you
can just specify like any kind of Min
and Max as well as a cell size and I
guess it will just kind of create that
in fact if we just take a look at where
this is actually coming from so here's
broad face grid so this is actually
owned by the Collision World which we
would expect and we update the grid and
find the objects that can collide
together so grid.update bodies and then
I'm guessing bodies is okay so we have
bodies is like a const vector here but
what this will do is clear resize and
then go through and let's see so we're
going to go through all of the bodies
um find all of this stuff
yeah okay well ignore if it's outside of
the Grove course and then otherwise it
looks like what we're doing here is just
creating a bounding box this is like an
ABB of the actual body meaning like if
we have a circle we'll get like the
bounds of it which would technically be
of course very kind of tightly around it
like this right and so basically X body
Min and Max this is like your X-Men your
X Max and then your y Min and your y Max
or possibly other way around and then I
guess what we do is sort them out into
their actual cells which is a vector of
vectors of collision bodies okay I'm
glad you joined the resize first of all
uh yeah it doesn't look like you're
doing okay yep and then you resize the
actual specific grid so we kind of the
way it's arranged it looks like because
this has grid column meaning that we
like grid X we get the specific column
so it looks like we have basically a
bunch of columns like this
this is kind of what the outer Vector is
and then once we're inside a specific
one that's us being like say inside this
guy now it's divided into I guess
specific cells and then each of these
cells of course will contain another
kind of vector with all of the actual
bodies inside it that's why this is a
vector of vectors because this kind of
outer Vector is the specific column and
then the inner Vector is the bodies
within that cell and then we'll go
through all of those and I guess push
them back into a specific grid cell
inside that column so we're just kind of
going through and actually creating the
spatial partitioning system and I guess
we're doing that every single uh frame
which is I mean in a way it's
unavoidable there are definitely better
ways to do this than just brute forcing
kind of your way through everything and
sorting it out until these buckets every
single frame but it's ultimately not a
bad way of doing it now whenever you
kind of are faced with this decision
it's always really important to just
think about the work that you're doing
to replace
other work so what I mean by that is
that clearly this grid update has
overhead right we have to Loop through
basically every single object in the
entire world and sort it out into like a
vector of vectors of vectors ultimately
we have our columns we have our rows and
then we have the bodies within each cell
right that's a lot of stuff to kind of
deal with so by adding this we're
clearly slowing down our performance
however why are we doing that it's so
that when we actually go through these
Collision pairs which we retrieve from
the grid we're able to dramatically
decrease this section right so this
section of code now the amount of times
we actually iterate through this is
going to be way less which again is
supposed to raise our performance but
what is really important to consider is
sometimes computers just do not work
like you expect them to sometimes in
your head you might think oh this is so
slow let me just let me just invent this
new new system to try and reduce this
workload but I see people doing this so
many times without actually even
profiling or benchmarking or doing
anything that would suggest them
measuring whether or not what they
expect the computer to do is actually
happening and again definitely not
saying this is a thing here because like
well we know that all of this is going
to be slower probably than partitioning
it but I'm just more using this as an
example like it's really important that
when you decide to commit to something
like this
you actually do a little sample a little
Benchmark to say okay what is the
current performance like like how long
is this actually taking and also am I
sure that the reason it's slow is
actually true right I haven't just made
this up I haven't just assumed that oh
well it's slow because the memory access
is slow or it's slow because the the
arithmetic kind of math that it has to
do is slow at the end of the day you're
a scientist you're a computer scientist
and scientists need to run tests so it's
really important that you actually do
that because then when you actually calm
down and you implement this and you
measure okay how much performance have I
lost by doing this right then the gain
is obviously supposed to be higher and
in many cases this happens honestly all
the time people will kind of do this
immediately and that's why I like
premature optimization is a rid of all
evil like even though I don't 100 agree
with that quote just as it stands
because there's so many caveats to that
and also because I think some people
just use that as an excuse to write bad
code like you shouldn't you shouldn't
intentionally write bad code like maybe
the maybe the reason you're making it
slows because you're just not a good
programmer and you're hiding behind the
whole premature optimization thing but
my point is with that quote if you do
decide to optimize without even knowing
the Baseline then what happens is I
might remove your optimization and it
might actually be faster and that's
really embarrassing right so just make
sure that you're always kind of
measuring this and making sure that your
assumption is correct because I guess my
point is if we look at this like it
there this is a bunch of overhead and
this unlike this this will actually go
through everybody in the entire like
World well everybody that I guess is
actually inside the grid extents right
it will go through everything and the
purpose of that is to avoid going
through everything here because when we
do that and we actually work out these
collisions and triggers then we actually
go in to solve collisions and we
actually go to the solver and we ask it
to solve stuff this is where all of the
code is right this is where all of the
math is this is where it's potentially
going to be really slow and this
specifically is what we are trying to
avoid and the way that these solvers are
divided here is we have like the ability
to have different solvers because
depending on like the the shapes or the
collisions there might be different
types so we have this kind of solar
generic class which just has a Sol
function with collisions to solve and
then we might have different
implementations such as smooth position
solver which is this guy over here and
then we also have an Impulse solver
which is what we were looking at before
so going through this I mean this is
pretty standard we have these collisions
that we iterate through body a body B
and manifold because Collision you can
see has body a body being manifold this
is a nice little way of pulling those
variables out of each actual Collision
struct honestly like I probably wouldn't
write it this way I don't really have a
reason for this it's just more of a
style thing I prefer to just kind of
have have const Collision Collision
right with our little reference here and
then just do Collision dot body a and
body B even though we have this kind of
collision prefix here and it might make
the code look a little bit more verbose
it's a little bit more clear about where
this is actually coming from this is
very subjective and this is also totally
fine and if anything it showcases a nice
little trick of pulling stuff out of
structs which I think is cool
um okay so if body is dynamic then body
a otherwise null pointer so if it's not
Dynamic then we don't cast it into a
rigid body so this is a way of basically
if it's Dynamic I guess because
Collision body is a base class we're
really doing like a a cast here like a
dynamic cast I guess to convert body a
which is just a collision body into
specifically a rigid body which is a
type of collision body so this is just a
way for us to kind of decide whether or
not we want this okay and then we get
the velocity so I mean this is a bit
weird because check this out like we've
got null pointer potentially and then
yeah I mean even even Visual Studio is
catching this so what you need to do is
well first of all don't do this right
but another really good kind of early
out here would be if a body like is null
and depending on how what you're doing
here because I think you're doing more
than just comparing Collision pairs you
might be doing that you could just early
out basically by saying if if these are
both null then just like continue
because there's nothing else to do here
if one of them is null then we can't we
probably can't Collide potentially but
we might still be able to actually
simulate the impulse because I'm
assuming that's what we have to do on
the one that's not null so that's why
you can't just do kind of or right
because um it doesn't necessarily mean
that's bad but that's definitely
something I would do to not waste my
time with the rest of this the other
thing is though this is that this is bad
though because if it's not Dynamic then
this will crash right so this is very
bad uh going through the rest of this
though okay with a little dot product
velocity along normal
blah blah blah here's the actual impulse
and then we have if a body uh okay so
here we actually do check for that being
false or not so what is this used for
this velocity just to get the relative
velocity and then we apply that and then
but relative velocity is used here so
yeah this is very Bad News Bears you
need to fix that
um but then over here we actually do
check to see if it's null and I guess if
it's not now we check to see if it's
kinematic so that's an interesting way
of doing it because I guess if a body is
not null then a body kinematic I would
have just written this as basically that
it's a little bit shorter so you're
basically making sure that first of all
a body isn't null so that's the same
thing as writing doesn't equal null
pointer but because of course a pointer
is a number and zero is an null pointer
we can just kind of treat it as a
Boolean in the sense that if it's a
non-zero number this will be true
otherwise if it's zero null pointer it
will be false so we can just check check
to make sure that that's basically not
zero and if it's not zero it proceeds to
this which will dereference the pointer
and check to see if it's kinematic or
not so that's what I would do here
instead of doing this kind of
interesting code which I have to say I
don't think I've ever seen this before
and I think I've seen someone checking
to see if that's not null because yeah I
mean you're doing the same thing here
actually I don't need to explain this
because you're doing the same thing here
you're checking to make sure you're
using a pointer kind of as a Boolean
expression but it's just that then
you're saying if it's true to that
otherwise false whereas of course like
that itself will return false and it
won't go into this Branch so I would
kind of change it to that and we do
friction just a bunch of fairly simple
math to be completely honest check out
brilliant if you're confused highly
recommend Link in the description below
uh yeah and then we have this kind of
situation here as well to actually set
the velocities here we're actually
applying the velocity and here we're
setting it to whatever that value should
be minus friction times mass uh yeah
pretty straightforward so that's kind of
the code I again overall I like the way
you've done the code like I can't really
fault it too much I guess the only thing
I would really say here is you are using
like you've got obviously you've made
your own classes which is fine I guess
for learning purposes and you are using
like the standard kind of library with
like abs and stuff I would probably
switch to glm they have all of these
classes and functions uh and of course
they'll have stuff like ABS and the
benefit there is that there's a lot more
kind of potential for performance
Improvement because glm can like take
advantage of simd it's just a very kind
of robust math Library well I mean I
don't know if I can say it's robust some
of it we've had a few issues with glm in
Hazel where they were just bugs but that
happens unfortunately everywhere and can
certainly happen in your code as well it
generally does does a good job um okay
cool I think that's pretty much it I
don't really have much else to say in
this code base I think that generally
you've done a very good job like this is
like I don't know should I start giving
ratings I think that overall I'd
probably rate this at like
somewhere between 80 and 90 right so
about eight or nine out of ten probably
bleeding more towards eight and this
rating of course is a little bit
subjective because it's going to depend
on me a lot but like the code itself and
the way that you've like laid it out the
way you've named things the way that
you've written like comments in these
places uh you know is generally good
you've used like unique pointers in the
right place you know there is some
regard to memory which is good I don't
think there's much regard to memory
layout but that's okay especially if
this is just like a little test project
and not something too advanced I would
probably like the only advice I'd give
is that if you if you take this project
and want to improve it have a go at
playing around with what I said in the
first episode of this Trilogy with
regards to to memory just test it out
for yourself try and move things away
from necessarily being pointers to
discrete kind of separate allocations of
Heap memory try to pull them together
into an arena and uh you know or just
like even stack allocations right just
try and keep that memory more together
in one block because at the end of the
day what you're doing with physics is
you are in fact iterating through a
whole bunch of just numbers a whole
bunch of numbers one after the other and
doing math on them and if they're all
kind of loaded up in the CPU cache ready
to be accessed ready to be you know
operated upon that's going to
dramatically speed things up the other
thing I would say is that remember when
we talked about the whole grid
partitioning system one other advantage
of having this set up is that obviously
what it means is that if we are in fact
operating on this guy we can't possibly
be touching you know this guy over here
right so these can't Collide which could
mean that what you could do is you could
kind of take chunks of this and you
could actually try and spread it out
across different threads and try and run
Collision detection or response or
physics simulation across like different
cores across different threads and that
can also speed it up it's a little bit
challenging to get that to work well
might not be as simple as it sounds but
I think it's definitely a fun Challenge
and multi-threading physics like that's
always a good idea I mean a lot of
physics simulations actually run on the
GPU in fact because at the end of the
day you have all of these kind of
discrete points and even though the kind
of detection response thing is a little
bit tired and you can't just you know
say that I'm going to simulate each one
of these guys on a separate GPU core and
everything's going to be good that might
work for particles because they don't
really collide with each other maybe
they collided with like a plane or some
kind of other like kind of physics
Collision body geometry in the level but
they don't really collide with
themselves so that's easy to do with
this it's a little bit more challenging
but I think it's well worth the
challenge and should be a lot of fun so
let me know if you do all that stuff I'd
love to take a look at this code again
sometime in the future with those
features thank you guys for watching
hope you guys enjoyed this episode don't
forget you can send in your code to
channelreview at gmail.com there'll be
some instructions in the description
below obviously don't forget to hit the
like button if you enjoyed the video
leave your thoughts in the comment
section below as well regarding like if
you agree with me if you disagree if
there's anything else you notice in the
code and finally don't forget to check
out brilliant.org the channel to learn
some math and I will see you guys next
time goodbye
thank you
foreign